most New Year's resolutions fail so in
this video I want to talk about the
science of why they fail and how to
avoid that so your New Year's
resolutions actually succeed and I want
to tell you about three of my New Year's
resolutions for 2020 the first one is to
stop going to news websites I find I
kill a ton of time by doing that now
don't get me wrong I do think it's
important to know what's going on in the
world but I just don't think following
the day-to-day developments of the news
cycle is the way to do that so instead I
am going to get one newspaper delivered
to my house every week and that is how I
am gonna stay informed
research has shown it is more effective
to make resolutions at new years than at
any other time of the year in fact one
study found that people who made
resolutions on January 1st were 10 times
as likely to stick with them 6 months
later than people who made their
resolutions at other times of the year
in January 1st 2020 is the first day of
a new decade so it may be even better
side note and those of you who want to
argue that the first day of the decade
is actually January 1st 2021 while you
may technically be correct because there
was no year 0 we went straight from 1 BC
to 180 for all intents and purposes
psychologically this January 1st is the
first day of the 2020s and that is what
matters
so the technicalities I think are
unimportant in this argument should be
put to bed the 2020s start on Jan 1 but
now the bad news even a resolution made
at New Year's will most likely fail
which is why gyms are packed in January
but they start to clear out by March
what research has found that only around
8% of people can stick with their
resolutions through the end of the year
so why is this and how do we avoid that
trap I think it all starts with a
misconception
Oh No
Oh No boo get well this is gonna be the
part of the video where I ran on the
treadmill with the treadmills just
broken so I think the misconception is
that people think that in order to make
big changes in their lives that they
have to make some sort of really big
effort I mean let's say your goal was to
run a marathon you might plan on running
ten kilometers
three times a week that seems kind of
proportionate to the end goal and you
might be excited and really motivated to
do it for the first few weeks but at
some point that motivation is gonna lag
and running 10k is gonna seem too hard
and so you're gonna sort of fall back
into old habits the misconception is
thinking you need to go big and so being
over ambitious with your goals and then
not being able to commit and stick to
them I'm gonna fix this the truth is
you're much better off if you pick small
targets that you can hit consistently
that's the idea behind James clears book
atomic habits which is this idea that if
you can get just 1% better every day at
something it will take a minimum amount
of effort but over time the effects will
compound just like compound interest and
James Clare proposes the two-minute rule
pick something that you can do in just
two minutes so if you want to run a
marathon start by say running two
minutes a day that is something that you
can't say you don't have time for and
once that habit sticks well then you can
try to extend it into something more
ambitious the next problem with
resolutions is they are too often vague
the most common resolutions that people
make are to lose weight exercise more
and to eat better the problem is those
things are so nondescript that it's hard
to know if you're making progress and
it's really easy to regress into your
old habits so the science around this
says you need to be specific and write
down your goals people who write down
their goals are 40% more likely to
achieve them that is pretty significant
just by taking that step of
putting pen to paper and I'm thinking
here in this video you should put your
New Year's resolutions in the comments
because at least that is taking a step
towards committing yourself to a goal
for the year my second new year's
resolution for 2020 is to write in a
daily planner every day of this year in
fact I can be more specific than that
I will write one word in this book each
day now I know one word might seem
unhelpfully ridiculously little to write
in this book but I want to commit to
this idea of starting small with the
idea that if I get in the habit of
making the time to at least write down
one word on each one of these pages well
then maybe some days I will write more
than one word and that will be helpful
in terms of planning my day a little bit
and so hopefully I will be more
productive than I would have been
otherwise and then it's really important
to track your progress in an obvious and
visual way and I'm going to use the
everyday calendar by Simone yet oddly
satisfying where there's a button for
every day of the year and you can push
it and the light turns on and that is
really satisfying so I think this will
encourage me to write down a word early
in the day so that I can go and turn on
the light for that day what's great
about this is it's a very visual way to
track my progress and to have it in an
obvious place where I can look at it all
the time and I'll put it in the back of
shot for some of my videos in 2020 so
you guys can see how I'm progressing
towards this goal so the third major
problem with New Year's resolutions is
that people seem to think it's about
having more willpower or motivation
being able to resist temptation better
but willpower is a finite resource and
it can be depleted that there are gonna
be some bad days and that is when you're
gonna relapse so relying on willpower is
not an effective strategy and research
has shown that people who have better
self-control actually just have to
exercise it less the way they're able to
do that is by structuring their
environments so they don't have to
exercise their willpower I find in my
kitchen it's always like the treats and
snacks which are left out on the counter
but the veggies which are like tucked
away in the vegetable crisper drawer and
I get it because you know that's where
the veggies are meant to go to keep them
crisp but the problem is if I don't see
them if they're not in my line of sight
I will just end up eating what's on the
counter and not going digging for
veggies so we need a way of changing our
environments so that we make better
choices which brings me to my third and
final new year's resolution for 2020 I
am deleting social media apps off of my
phone I'm getting rid of Instagram and
Twitter you are watching the exact
moment that I do that
the reason for this is I find I just
kill way too much time going into these
apps and research shows that any tiny
distraction that you have during your
day takes you you know something like
20-25 minutes to get back into your work
and so I'm losing a lot of time to just
procrastinating with these apps so I'm
getting rid of them off my phone so I
don't have to use my willpower to not
click them mindlessly as I normally
would and I've actually downloaded an
app that will block news sites and block
my social media while I'm working
because that way I don't have to
restrain myself the systems that I put
in place will restrain me for me I know
a lot of this sounds a little bit CGP
grey but I think he's onto something you
don't need to follow the day-to-day
movements of the news cycle and you do
not need to be scrolling social media
all the time particularly when you're
trying to get useful work done so that's
how I feel
I want to optimize my 2020 by locking
down all my potential distractions not
needing any willpower and I've got some
small specific and written down targeted
with tracking plans for 2020 so I'd love
to know what
you're planning for 2020 for your New
Year's resolutions what are your plans
for the next decade
hey this episode of veritasium is
supported by viewers like you on patreon
and by audible you know what's an
excellent habit listening to one
audiobook every month and as an audible
member that's easy because each month
you get one credit good for any
audiobook you JH selection now a couple
of the audiobooks I have on my phone are
atomic habits by James clear and deep
work by Cal Newport and I was real
istening to these books recently when I
was taking my kids out for nap drives
and in fact it was on one of these
drives that I came up with my new year's
resolutions for 2020 and hence this
episode so to browse their unmatched
selection of audio content go to AUD
ible comm slash veritasium or text
veritasium to 500 500 right now audible
members get more than ever before in
addition to one audiobook you get access
to two audible originals plus exclusive
guided fitness and meditation programs
and the book that I am listening to next
is called behave the biology of humans
at our best and worst by Robert Sapolsky
it explains why we make the decisions we
do in all sorts of situations from our
most altruistic to our most selfish or
vengeful and you can join me and start
listening with a 30-day trial and your
first audiobook plus two audible
originals free when you go to
audible.com slash veritasium or text
veritasium that's V er I TAS I um - 500
500 so I want to thank audible for
supporting me and I want to thank you
for watching